hey friends welcome back to Deep dive
the podcast where it's my immense
pleasure to sit down with entrepreneurs
creators authors and other inspiring
people and we find out how they got to
where they are and the strategies and
tools we can learn from them to help
build a life that we love now this
episode is a little bit different
because we're going over seven
unconventional truths that will help you
level up your productivity and these are
taken from a diverse range of episodes
that I've done with various people who
are specialists in productivity authors
and academics and entrepreneurs and I
hope that by listening to these seven
different tips there might be at least
one thing that you can take away as an
experiment try and apply to your own
life so without further Ado here we are
I think of productivity as a phase it's
a phase phase in someone's life okay
there is a a phase in your life or it
could recur so there could be different
phases where you have to think about
productivity and then there's other
phases where you think about creativity
I really see productivity and creativity
as two sides to the same coin uh and
where I learned about this was from my
dad my dad is one of the most creative
people I've ever met wildly imaginative
creative but how do does that creativity
make it out into the world is
productivity so he has these these very
systematic approaches and routines and
rules that he uses from you know the
time of day that he paints from this
time to this time to how long he's going
to spend on each stage of a painting to
the way that he takes notes and so I see
this kind of like pendulum productivity
creativity productivity creativity and
if you go too far on either end of the
spectrum you start hitting diminishing
returns and you start to get stuck right
like like on both you can get so fixated
on productivity your work starts to
become formulaic it starts to become
very boring and it's time to to kind of
go to the other end of the spectrum
creativity but then you can go too far
in creativity that's when you get too
precious you get too oh no this my art
it has to be the certain way and you
know you talk to someone six months
later what are you doing oh I'm working
on my my one painting for the last six
months that also doesn't work you're not
you're getting stuck you're getting
you're getting sort of locked up in your
own preciousness and so so I I really
see them as this kind of alternating
back and forth pendulum nice yeah I had
I had a bit of a thought as you were
saying that and I think i' I've never
really thought of the two as being being
separate I I I guess you know given that
a bunch of videos I make happen to be
vaguely themed around productivity when
people ask me oh what is productivity to
you I kind of take a step back I broaden
it out and I say oh productivity is just
using your time intentionally yeah um
which then makes it a more like gentle
definition that you can apply to your
personal life to your work life and who
doesn't want to use the time
intentionally but there's something
about the word productivity that feels a
bit more like G it feels very worky and
very much like I'm generating economic
output for my employer and this is a bad
thing yeah um any any thoughts on that
yeah a couple things um so productivity
is like efficiency efficiency is sort of
a synonym right what is efficiency if
you again if you go back to
manufacturing it's simply minimizing
waste it's how I think of it which is
one of the most important things in life
like when people say say productivity
doesn't matter I go does it not matter
that you not waste your time you know
does it not matter that you waste your
attention does it not matter that you
waste your ideas does it not matter that
you waste your potential like isn't that
like almost what life is about and it's
easy to lose sight of that if you think
of efficiency but I I really just think
about it as minimizing waste uh and then
the other thing I was going to say oh
think about other uses of the word
productivity a productive conversation
would you say a productive conversation
is
is you know not is uh is antihuman or is
not benevolent or is kind of removing
the humanity no I want all my the most
intimate conversation with my wife I
still want to be productive that doesn't
mean it's not a good conversation um or
alternatively think of a productive
ecosystem productive ecosystem the
forest is a productive ecosystem not
because we went in and clearcut
everything and built a parking lot but
because there is value being created
right and you could say economic value
but I just think of there's plants being
grown there's animals that are surviving
there's Evolution that's happening
there's families animals and humans that
are being raised from the sustenance of
the forest so I kind of like to to use
the word productivity because it
confronts people that's what I like I
want people to be confronted okay
because the same thing that has you kind
of be triggered by productivity if you
follow that thread you're going to get
to an incorrect assumption a limiting
belief a blind spot that is going to
limit you in life and in your career oh
that is beautiful I can feel my kind of
mindset changing about that because I've
also been like yeah I agree productivity
is a bit of a dirty word so let's not
use that word let's call it
intentionality or something like that
but I like how you're just like yep
productivity is a good thing one of the
lines that I I was listening to the
audiobook and and you said sometimes
productivity can be self-care and I was
like o that's interesting what's what's
going on with that so I think that's one
of the like one of the main triggers for
the book was the fact that like people
would be like oh self-care relax and I'd
be like actually sometimes self-care is
meeting that deadline that you're
currently not on track to meet but
actually respecting your future self and
your goals is getting the up and
doing the work that you need to do for
that and like we cannot Market self-care
as always like doing nothing sometimes
self-care is working harder because
you're currently not working in line
with what you want to make happen and I
think that again the internet hates that
because it's like it doesn't fit into
this idea of like well-being versus
productivity it's the actual
understanding of the fact that both are
one and the other like self-care isn't
always running a bath if you're running
a bath and you're about to miss three
deadlines and that's your paycheck for
the week self-care is not running a bath
I refuse to believe that self-care is
running a bath so that was a lot of the
stuff in the book is around how to
action actual self-care and like how to
know at what point something will be
self-care and some and it versus
self-sabotage or any of these things to
create a life that revolves around you
know your boundaries and where you need
to be more productive and where you
probably need to stop being so harsh on
yourself nice what are your uh two
different types of doing nothing yes CU
I thought that was super interesting
like the distinction and I I had one of
those over the weekend it was a Saturday
no no one El in the house I was like I'm
going to make all this book progress and
I made zero book progress just browsed
YouTube all day and I was listening to
the audio book last night I was like oh
if I had this terminology of of like
it nothing I would have called it I
would have just like written the day off
but I didn't until I felt guilty for the
whole day nightmare so I think that's
really really important and I think that
when we're taught so much how to work
and we're not taught that well how to
take time and know when we're probably a
little bit burnt out and all of these
different things that actually if we
took rest we would be much better
tomorrow the idea of planned nothing and
it nothing are the fact that
actually I believe wholeheartedly in
time management
I believe that time management is Stress
Management for some people you're going
to be very like taipe and it's going to
be like of course you're you're time
managing like of course at the beginning
of your week you know what your whole
week looks like and all of this other
people are going to be like no I won't
know till the day I do believe though
that if you want to fit a certain amount
of things in you have to be good at time
management and you have to do your
10,000 hours and make yourself good at
time management you don't have to want
to fine but do I think that it's really
important to also give a bit of tough
love and be like if you want to do XY
and Z you have to plan it's not going to
happen without you planning it so
whether that's starting to go to the gym
whether that's starting a new side
hustle or a new hobby or any of those
things if you're not planning those
things in in the same way as if you
don't plan in the gym or you know if you
don't put your doctor's appointment in
your diary it's not going to happen so
the idea of like plan nothing and
it nothing is when you're looking at
your week plan and you're doing or your
day plan and you're doing your plan for
yourself I think it's really important
to have enough planned nothing in there
and I don't think we do that because
planning nothing again seems quite
oxymoronic it doesn't make sense but
knowing your boundaries and getting to
know how you're most productive and how
you're happiest happiest is really
really important and that all comes then
into your time management so for me for
example I know that from a Monday to
Thursday so weekdays I'm probably going
to want to do something two nights and
do nothing two nights and that's my
limit usually so like this week I've had
something every single night and I hate
it I feel dead I've started every day
feeling like an absolute zombie I don't
have any thinking time I don't have time
to stare at the ceiling like I don't you
know I'm not able to kind of process
things in the same way and so I get
anxious about things and I get stressed
and I don't feel like I I'm my best self
the way we mitigate that is by
understanding those boundaries and for
me usually if I look at next week for
example and I've got something in on
Wednesday and Thursday and someone says
are you free on Tuesday I'm not I'm
actually not free on Tuesday it might
look if you look at my diary like I'm
free but I'm not these are my
non-negotiables and this is how I manage
myself to be able to be my best self for
my goals whether those are personal life
whether those are work it nothing
is understanding that we can plan as
much as we want we can operate by those
rules we can you know I can know that
I'm going out Wednesday and Thursday
next week for dinner and I can know that
I'm doing Tuesday Monday and Tuesday in
and then whatever at the weekend I've
got it all planned and I can get to
Wednesday and I can be like I actually I
actually either don't want to or I can't
or I'm feeling really burnt out or my
mental health isn't there or any of
those things and understanding that we
can plan for absolutely everything and
we can't plan for the fact that we're
human and so it nothing is
essentially being able to be like
it not doing that and I think important
distinction again is like you get a real
dopamine hit when you think you had to
do something and then you don't have to
do something so you have a plan with
some someone and then you you cancel
that plan you get that dopamine here but
then also you can get into the habit of
doing that because you think you need
that and actually what you needed was to
push yourself out there and go out to
dinner and have a good laugh with
someone you haven't caught up with in a
while but it feels like a chore when
you're at the end of that day and you're
like that's the last thing I want to do
so I think understanding as well the
boundaries of it nothing too are
really important but I do think that if
we don't have it nothing say your
Saturday night where you were going to
make a huge amount progress with the
book and you decide not to what you
really needed in that time was it
nothing you needed to be like it
I'm doing absolutely nothing instead you
probably sat on the sofa being like I
meant to be doing something and then
felt probably you probably didn't get
the benefit of doing nothing and you
didn't get the benefit of doing work and
so I think understanding our human
limits and our boundaries and being able
to just say I'm not going to do that and
I know I'm not going to do that and I'm
okay with not doing that is one of the
most important things you can do for
your productivity and your time
management and your selfcare what is
slow
productivity proba so yeah so if we
don't have like here's the issue with
knowledge work in general the issue
we've been grappling with in the last 20
minutes like what does productivity even
mean right and and so then it just
becomes this weird catch all or
Boogeyman so I have this thought of like
why don't we actually positively come
out and come up with a definition that
we like a definition that's human a that
that melds well with our human instincts
in the way our brain is actually wired
that's centered around producing
meaningful and valuable things but in a
way that's very sustainable in a way
that's very satisfying so so instead of
just pushing Back Against The Boogeyman
productivity like let's put in place an
alternative and the alternative I've
been working on is called slow
productivity and like the slow food
movement or these other movements I've
I've I've gone back and pulled from
these sort of existing cultures of
knowledge workers that have been around
for centuries in some cases millennia
that had the privilege and space to kind
of figure out what's the best way to
work with your mind you know what works
what doesn't and figuring out can we
have a widely applicable definition of
productivity comes out of it and so slow
productivity has three principles to it
do fewer things working at a natural
pace obsessing over
quality I think those three things
approaching knowledge work with those
three principles realigns the efforts
with uh our Humanity the way we're wired
I can give you a a neuros science
argument for it I can give you a
psychological argument for it I can give
you a philosophical argument for those
three things all on all three of those
levels orienting knowledge work around
that is Meaningful satisfying you can
produce things of Great Value it can be
very productive for companies and it can
be very satisfying for individuals so
I'm I'm sort of putting together my
pitch of what what Target of
productivity should people who make a
living using their brains what it what
should they be going for Beyond just you
know get after it have your to-dos
organized I don't know what's what's the
philosophical
well there's uh like we can go back to
Aristotle if we need to right there
there's this the what what is the the
Theology of of human existence well
what's the one thing we have that other
creatures don't is we have these brains
that can sit and think and create things
um and there's there's a there's a
there's an argument towards the the the
production of things of value and
meaning and and sort of giving things
the time they require craftsmanship that
there there's a real philosophical
Foundation to the human value that's
extracted from actually like doing
things of of value of impact with your
mind and a lot of that gets sapped away
when you're just answering emails all
day uh or just hustling to get after it
you could go all the way back to n i
mean this is the the thing I'm working
on now is I I've gone back heavily to do
a deep into the mainly social
anthropological research to do a deep
history of work for 300,000 years what
was work for humans because that's a
long enough time span that our brain
evolved right to to match this
definition of work and and you know
surprise surprise when you go back and
look through this deep literature you
see not doing too many things sees
variation in Pace and intensity a lot of
your time being the application of hard
one skills like that's exactly what
comes up that's what we did for 300,000
years so there there's also this almost
like psychology anthropological even
neuroscientific argument for not being
overloaded varying your intensity in
various ways and spending more of your
time like hard one skills like what we
expect work to
be do you have you stumbled across any
kind of um dbar number for number of
active projects that one should have at
a given time like when you say fewer
things how few are we talking well yeah
I mean I so there there's two different
time scales I mean at the scale of like
what you're working on right now it's
one right so like in the what what we
cannot do what our brain cannot do is
concurrently during like the afternoon
go back and forth between three
different things and just the way our
planning motivation Loop works like we
have one thing in our working memory we
build this internal model that pulls
episodic memories out of the hippocampus
we use that to try to predict what we
should do next that system cannot handle
more than one thing so we cannot be
thinking about making decisions on or
making progress on more than one thing
at a time and I don't mean like
literally at the time like over a couple
hours even like work on one thing till
you're done move on to the other thing
our brain cannot go back and forth It's
why email like going back and forth
between your email just crushes us
psychologically uh you know a recent
podcast episode I talked about task
freeze where you see like 15 things you
need to do and you just stop it's
because you literally the planning
motivational Center of your brain can't
make plans for 15 things at the same
time it neurologically can't do that so
your motivation system just freezes up
right so at a time one thing in terms of
like ongoing projects I'm a big believer
in like poll-based methodology where
there's like two or three things you're
two or three things you're working on
when something finishes you can pull
something else in you know and I
actually think this is how companies
should organize work software developers
already do this but I think we should do
this more broadly in knowledge work
where yeah there's a lot of work the
company needs to do don't just
distribute that to everyone's plate and
everyone has 20 things that they have to
kind of figure out what to do with they
should just be working on a couple
things and they can pull in new things
once they once it's ready and the
problem why you need why I think this is
important and why I think it's kill to
have a lot of things on your plate even
if you're not working on them at the
exact same time is there's something
called an overhead tax that every
project that you have committed to
generates it's a overhead of
administrative work that you have to do
even if you're not actively working on
the project it's emails you have to send
uh meetings planning meetings standing
meetings you have to have and and just
cognitive load of knowing it's there so
that builds up so if you have 15
projects on your plate you're paying
overhead tax on 15 projects and that tax
take takes up your time and before you
know it most of your time and mental
energy is going to the maintenance of
the ongoing projects and almost nothing
gets done and then you fall farther
behind and then the the you more
projects build up and the tax gets worse
I call it the overhead spiral it's a
terrible state to be in so there there's
a real cost to having too many things on
your plate even if you're very careful
about this morning I'm just working on
this and then in the afternoon I'm just
working on that and on Tuesdays I work
on this once you get past a certain
level it's a problem and I think again
it's something companies get wrong they
just say let's distribute the task
informally to everyone we'll have
everything live on people's individual
plates and they can just figure out what
to work on and what not uh and the
overhead tax kills them like a much
better system is this all sits in a
holding tank and when I'm ready for the
next thing I pull it in but until it
leaves that holding tank I'm paying no
overhead tax on it it's not actually
it's not actually my view so I honestly
think like three active projects at a
time is best and obviously when you're
working on something you're only working
on that one thing yeah this is actually
something like as of last week we have
now started of doing in our in our team
and it's I'm so surprised it's taken so
long to get to this because we were in
that model of oh there's all these
things we could do let's just like
distribute them but now we're like oh
actually let's do the thing that
software people do and actually make a I
mean we have like a bucket list of we
would love to to have have my website
contain book summaries of every book
I've ever read we'd love to make think
about a patreon we'd love to think about
making our own keyboard we'd love to
think about making our own bag we'd love
to think about this enormous list of
things but not right now like for the
next six weeks we're just focusing on
these things good then six weeks later
we can reassess the bucket list and see
okay whether we actually want to put
things onto it and that model has uh
basically is like within half an hour
freed up a lot of cognitive overload
from people being like Oh actually this
is not a priority right now so therefore
I'm not going to think about it until
our next six week Sprint planning or
whatever that looks like yep yep that's
100% right by the way that's what
everyone should be doing I I have a
chapter about this in the new book I I
wrote a couple weeks ago everyone should
be doing that but mainly only software
people do and it's such a uh it's such a
it's such a such an unnecessary unforced
source of stress and overhead I mean
just this is what I think happened by
the way with the zoom apocalypse so I
don't know if you heard this from your
listeners I definitely was getting this
feedback that during 2021 when everyone
we were everyone was remote knowledge
workers were remote people got to these
sort of absurd states where like all
they were doing was Zoom eight hourss a
day they're like wait there's no work
left like it became absurd it was like a
cough cup play or something like this
like sort of like meta commentary on on
the absurdity of of work and bureaucracy
or something like that but I what this
was I think was like a really clear
example of the overhead tax spiraling
out of control because when when people
went remote it increased the amount of
task on their plate by like 20% all of a
sudden because you had to figure out how
to run whatever you do remote so it
generated new work right to figure out
how do we make the transition and
switching over to uh
video is there's efficiencies that
that's lost so there's a lot of
efficiencies in person where where I can
grab you at the end of a meeting be like
wait hold on like what are we doing
about this client coming tomorrow we go
back and forth for three minutes and
figure it out when I can't do that
anymore we're left saying like we should
have a zoom meeting yeah to talk about
the client but what's the smallest
interval on your calendar 30 minutes and
so now five minutes becomes 30 minutes
so I think the the the zoom apocalypse
that happened in like the summer of 2020
was making the phenomenon of overhead
tax unavoid visible like it it's like
look we we we up these things by about
20% and soon all time went away for
working all time went away for working
and it showed how how perilous like how
how much we we we pushed that tax up
almost to the Limit like before the
pandemic we must have already been
spending so much of our time just
talking about work because when it got
20% worse we couldn't ignore it anymore
because people were riding me and saying
I don't know when to go to the bathroom
because it's back to back to back to
back to back for seven hours of you know
Zoom like it got so absurd that people
were like okay obviously this this can't
right but we were like right below that
for years and years so I think it's a
huge phenomenon and and we really should
spend more time thinking about it yeah
this episode of Deep dive is very kindly
sponsored by hostinger now if you're
looking to start a business or develop
some kind of brand then you're probably
going to need a website and if you've
ever wanted to set up a website but
you're not sure where to start then
hostinger has everything you need
hostinger is a top Global website
hosting service with servers all around
the world it's fast and it's reliable
and it's got over 2 million users and
it's becoming one of the fastest growing
web hosting Services out there now I
personally really love hostinger because
it is so easy to use and it's fantastic
for me and fantastic for my team because
we don't have to deal with too much faf
and too much setup and if you're new to
website design they've also got
everything you need to build your
website rather than just to host it and
recently they've added a really cool AI
website builder which lets you build a
sort of professional looking website or
at least the first draft of it in
literally seconds it is super easy to
use there is a drag and drop editor that
lets you customize stuff and you don't
need to have any coding or like CSS HTML
knowledge at all hostinger comes to less
than $3 a month and that includes a free
domain name as well so it's super
affordable and if you use the link in
the video description so hostinger.com
Al abdal and on the checkout page you
type in Ali abdal in all caps then that
will give you 10% off your plan as well
so thank you so much again hostinger for
sponsoring this podcast this episode of
Deep dive is very kindly sponsored by
snipp now snipp is an amazing app that's
absolutely going to revolutionize the
way you listen to podcasts I've been
using it for the last 2 months and it's
become my absolute favorite way to
listen to podcast because the cool thing
about snipped is that it's not just a
podcast player what it does is allow you
to create Snips of each podcast that you
listen to to where if you hear something
that particularly Vibes with you all you
need to do is tap your headphones and
the app will save it and then it's like
this ridiculously fancy AI transcription
type feature that will listen to the
last like minute of the podcast it will
figure out what's being said and it will
create a little snippet or a little snip
where it will summarize and it will give
you like the notes from exactly what was
said and then you can click edit on it
and you can like set the start point and
the end point it's basically like being
able to highlight a podcast as if you
were reading a book now this is really
helpful if you want to remember the
kinds of things that you hear in
podcasts and it's also really helpful if
like me you are some sort of content
creator and you benefit from sharing
your insights with other people which
even if you're not a content creator is
just a nice thing to do generally and
the other cool thing about this Snips
feature is that you can see where other
people have snipped a particular podcast
and so you know we all have way too many
podcasts to listen to these days but you
can browse through and you can see ooh
that episode of Deep dive was snipped
4,000 times and that one was only
snipped 2,000 times so you know what let
me prioritize listening to the one with
4,000 Snips because more people have
highlighted it and then you can even
browse through the highlights so if you
haven't got time to listen to the whole
podcast you can go through the various
Snips and you can decide is this podcast
worth you listening to and because it's
a powerful AI tool it also generates
transcripts and chapters for basically
every podcast which means even if the
podcaster hasn't like created those
chapters already they'll automatically
create them using the AI features and so
you can again skip around in podcasts to
the various bits that might interest you
the most and actually it turns out that
deep dive listeners already love using
snipp because we are actually the fifth
most popular podcast on the snipp
platform so if you want to give it a go
and you want to level up your ability to
listen to podcasts and take notes at the
same time then head over to sn.com
deepdive that's s
nipd snpd like snip with a d on the end
of it sn.com deepdive and that link is
going to be in the show notes and also
in the video description if it's easier
for you to click on it and if you sign
up via that link or that URL in the next
month then you will get a completely
free 30-day trial of snipped and then
you can try it out for the entire 30
days and you can take all these notes
and you can see if it Vibes with you so
thank you so much snip for sponsoring
this episode one of the things that
really resonated with me was the way you
described the Rocks analogy I wonder if
you can talk a little bit about that oh
yeah yeah talking stereotypical bad time
management I mean okay I feel like
caveat one or two people have explained
to me since the book came out ways in
which it's possible to interpret this
parallel Parable that are that are not
so ridiculous but in case anyone doesn't
know about it a in various different
versions but it's like the teacher or
somebody like brings in a jar of should
I go through this whole thing or is it
so well known that this is a waste of uh
valuable I think it's worth going
through I'm not sure it's that I it's
it's it's well known to to people like
you and me okay just very quickly and
you decide whether to use it or not a
teacher brings a glass jar into a
classroom with um some large rocks some
Pebbles and some sand and challenges the
students to fit all of this into the
glass jar and then the students because
they're apparently like really dumb
start putting the the sand in first and
the pebbles in first then they find the
big rocks won't fit so then teacher says
no no no let me show you how to do it
and he says so you put the big rocks in
first then you can fit the Pebbles and
then pour the sand in all fits and the
idea is um if the big rocks are your
major priorities in life you've got to
make time for those and you can make
time for those and if you do make time
for those then everything else you can
fit in around the edges but if you don't
put those first you'll never get round
to them at all and I don't think that's
a completely meritless point I just want
to say that right now so that you know
the estate of Steven Cy doesn't
come me excuse you for
Li but the experiment is is plainly
rigged right it's set up the the the
professor the teacher has only brought
as many big rocks in as he knows can
ultimately with the right configuration
be made to fit and I think that
extending this metaphor the the the
problem most of us have with time
management these days the main one it
it's not necessarily that we're bad at
prioritizing it's just that there are
too many big rocks to fit in the jar in
other words there are too many things
that totally legitimately have a claim
on your time too many people in your
life business opportunities demands from
the boss whatever you're setting it
whatever your situation is like there
are just too many things that
legitimately you could use your time on
than you have the time and stamina yeah
available for so the nature of the hard
Choice involved is different it's not
just like how am I going to organize my
day it's like what am I going to neglect
because I'm and what what important
things am I going to neglect because I
am definitely going to be neglecting
some important things yeah like as I was
listening to the book it it really gave
me a lot of reassurance
um because again as a productivity Guru
I feel like I should have my life in
order and you know when the WhatsApp
messages pile up to like you know 100
plus I'm like oh my God relationships
are the most important thing in life I'm
letting people down but not replying to
them and then I spend hours replying to
all the people and then responding to
WhatsApp messages uh generates more
WhatsApp messages similarly to
responding to email just generates more
emails um and you know at the same time
I care about the work stuff I care about
like I don't know some sort of impact I
care about spending time with my family
and it's like in the past part of me was
just like you know what I just really
suck at keeping in touch with friends
and that's okay and then another part of
me was like no that shouldn't be okay
like you know I should use my
productivity powers to like actually
focus on this thing that's important
like keeping in touch with friends how
how do you I guess knowing that for
example there are too many rocks to fit
in the jar mhm how how does one go about
Sol quote solving this problem well I
think so there sort of I think the most
important point there is that like in a
certain sense you can't and that's the
really important point and this is not a
despairing message I think it's a really
empowering and sort of thrilling message
in a way but like if the if the
challenge and like I I I so like Vibe
with what you're saying there
about feeling that there must be a
solution and that all these things
really matter they do really matter you
don't need to persuade yourself that
actually some of them don't matter just
to get really sort of existential about
it I think there is some kind of urge
motivating that and it's almost
Universal to want to find a cheat code
for life or find a sort of you know a
caveat in the contract of being being
human and and to get on top of
everything or in command of your time in
a way in a certain way that is just not
actually available to us as finite
creatures because we have this
fundamental mismatch between our
capacity to think of infinite
possibilities and feel infinite
obligations and our abil our finite
material you know short lives and and
limited time so this is like the vague
part and we can totally talk about like
more specific and practical things but
but I think there's something really
powerful in just seeing Oh this isn't a
problem to be solved this is just the
way things are at the end of life there
will be lots and lots of things you
didn't get around to doing that that
totally were legit that there would have
been good things to do but that was
because you were doing other thing
hopefully things that were that were
good things to do and you can sort of
relax into the discomfort of that a
little bit you can sort of you can feel
the anxiety or anyway leads to anxiety
in me that comes from thinking like well
you mean I'm never going to get to this
point in my life where I have no
problems or feel no it's like no you're
not that and that would be ridiculous
and you wouldn't want to get there
actually but it's a separate discussion
um you can sort of factor in like price
in to your to your approach to life that
there are going to be good relationships
that you don't uh nurture interesting
opportunities that you don't pursue
great books that you don't get to to
read it's like once that's if something
like that is compl completely a given it
stops being stressful we don't beat
ourselves up for not being able to like
jump a mile in the air because nobody
expects that in the first place of human
beings and it's the it should be the
same for this kind of stuff and once you
sort of let this whole Fantastical
edifice crash to the ground and you're
just standing in the rubble you can be
like okay now I've got this many hours
today what would be the most meaningful
exciting high impact things to do and
it's like it's it's hard and I don't
want to imply that I've like totally
this this this issue either but like I
think that is the way forward what sort
of tools were you using to stay
productive before it coalesced into the
method everything I was like a hopeless
early adopter it's like new app I would
be on it immediately
and sometimes it helped me here or
sometimes it helped me there but it's
it's it's I don't know um I mean you
name it I probably use the app I used
the system I used all of it and what's
funny is that I learned so much more
after after I started sharing like Bojo
work right people are like oh have you
heard of David Allen I'm like no I
hadn't I probably should have at some
point but like all these great thinkers
in the space and I'm like okay what do
they say about this stuff and it's been
really exciting for me because I'm as
much of a student of all this stuff as I
am a teacher and so yeah I continue to
use stuff all the time you know like I I
love this stuff it's fun it's like okay
how do I make more how do I make better
use of my time and so what were the dots
that connected for you to result in that
oh this is this is the pen and paper
based method that I have found the most
most helpful like having having tried
these like thousand different things um
okay so there are a couple things there
one is it's not done which is the fun
part right like here are the here's the
minimum valuable product that's kind of
what I share with people like you're the
fewest amount of tools I found to be
successful over the longest period of
time try them on for size and see if
they work for you um I think that I
never intended on sharing this so maybe
we can approach it from that angle what
happened was that people always saw me
sitting down with a notebook especially
in the as somebody that's a digital
native and working in digital design
people like you always have a notebook
what are you doing in there I'm like
well thinking that's what I'm doing I'm
trying to figure out stuff drawing
whatever it's a canvas and then people
would be like well so how would you deal
with this problem or how would you deal
with this problem or how would you
organize this and I would show them like
one piece of the methodology or at that
time just what I was doing and I found
over and over again that no matter what
their background was it would be useful
especially for people who only did
things online and I was like huh maybe I
should share some of this stuff um and
that's kind of what ended up
incentivizing me to coales everything to
share it and so I stripped everything
out but the most helpful tools that had
the things that had worked over the
longest period of time and a lot of
that's just about writing down your
thoughts that's the core of it like in
bullet Journal you write down three
things the things you have to do the
things that you experience and the
things you don't want to forget and then
you come back to those things in regular
intervals that's the
greatly diminished uh version of bullet
journaling it's writing things down and
reading what you wrote and trying to
connect the dots over time so those
three three those three things were
writing down what you have to do tasks
events and notes tasks events and
notes okay yeah I guess that's kind of
what mine looks like as well but but
because so I guess you must get this a
lot but I like I I first I mean I'd
heard of the the method like years ago
on some random productivity blog or
something I always thought oh
interesting like I'll file that in for
later to try at some point and then uh
my friend Matt Della did a video
recently where he tried bullet
journaling I was like huh okay
interesting like it's not too artsy FY
like I I sort of imagined it would be
sure and then I started watching a few
other videos about it I was like oh this
actually is really helpful like I I need
a way to look at my year for the whole
year because I think like the problem
with Google Calendar is that like
it's forces you to think very zoomed in
and if you try and zoom out like
suddenly you can't see anything at all
because now it's just little dots on on
a thing and like oh this this like
future log thing seems great oh like
month at a glance yeah i' that that
would be really helpful just being able
to see my calendar at a glance and
figure out like you know where where do
I have blocks in my calendar where I
should probably take some time off and
go on holiday or something and oh you
know this daily thing of like actually
figuring out what your most important
task is for the day or what what tasks
you have to do I was sort of doing a
version of that and so we we released
our own like stationary line which where
it's like every day is a page and it
asks you three things you're grateful
for it asks you what's your most
important task and the sort of the might
Tod do list things that you might you
might want to do with like a little
brain dump area um and I was like I'm
also I'm already kind of using this this
sort of most important task method let's
let's try this bullet Journal thing and
then I came across the book and I
listened to the book on Audible and I
think that might have been a mistake
because it was it was like hard to
imagine what was going on when just
listening to it on Audible and so I
think that that's one of the tricky
things about this because I guess it's
it is somewhat visual but I guess like
with with that caveat in mind so like
what are the like the core principles I
guess of of the method um and obviously
people we'll put links to the the book
which I recommend not getting on Audible
because then you can you can you can see
what's going on when you get it on
Kindle or or in real life it really
helps to see what's being talked about
for sure
um okay tasks events notes task tasks
events and notes so I'm trying to think
of a way to have a non-visual yeah
version of describing this I I think the
best way to think about it is writing
down your thoughts in a really dis Ed
way so a lot of
people know how powerful journaling can
be right they hear about all the mental
health benefits that it can have and I
very much encourage long form journaling
but it takes a lot of time yeah right
and a lot of people see it only as an
emotional thing right it's like I I
Journal when I'm confused or when I'm
sad or when I'm angry and that can be
helpful and then you have bulleted
bullet lists which essentially are for
very specific things this is what I have
to buy you know the these are my goals
these are all these things so bullet
journaling kind of combines The Best of
Both Worlds where it helps you organize
your thoughts as bulleted list that's
one component there's two parts of the
bullet Journal method the system and the
practice the pr the system is how you
organize information and then the
practice is more about what you do with
what you write down I like to say that
you know writing down writing things
down is only the beginning so you write
down the things that you experience so
your events the things that you don't
want to forget which are your notes and
then uh your tasks things that are
actionable right okay sorry please go
ahead and each one of those has a
different icon in front of it so as
you're writing things down you're also
categorizing your thoughts in real
time and the only way to make that
sustainable is figure out a way to write
down less right you're really trying to
focus on what really matters and that is
part of the practice right you listen to
somebody and you're like it focuses it
helps you become an active listener
right it's like what about this is the
takeaway specifically so you're starting
to think about what's being said in a
very different way because like hearing
and listening are two very different
things so it's okay what about this is
important and then using your own words
to capture it and that process as well
like using your own words helps you
retain it better and helps you make it
more personal all these things and
you're doing this throughout the day so
information that's coming from the
outside being filtered through your
brain and then being added to your
bullet Journal so that's like a big part
of it capturing things and you record so
the Bullet Journal method Works in a
cycle which is record reflect refine and
respond and those are like the four
steps so you record by writing things
down then you reflect on the things that
you wrote down and try to come up with
insights and different takeaways and
then you take action accordingly right
that's essentially what you're trying to
do the bullet Journal creates both a
framework for you to organize your
information but also how to think about
your information and then make all that
Insight actionable that's the big part
like what do you do with what you learn
by the way in case you haven't heard my
brand new book Feelgood productivity is
now out it is available everywhere books
are sold and it's actually hit the New
York Times and also the Sunday Times
bestseller list so thank you to everyone
who's already got a copy of the book if
you've read the book already I would
love a review on Amazon and if you
haven't yet checked it out you may like
to check it out it's available in
physical format and also ebook and also
audio book book everywhere books are
sold there's a great story that you tell
in your new book some days today um
about um I think you had a lunch with
someone and they were a few minutes late
like seven minutes late or something I
wonder if you can you can tell that
story because that that's one that's
really really stuck with me so I always
am willing to give fledgling writers 30
minutes of my time if they will meet me
in the place that I happen to be and I
was in McDonald's that day which is
actually one of my favorite places to
meet writers it's um I like the sort of
tearing away of all of what people see
as writing which is you know I need to
be at a coffee shop with smooth jazz and
a cappuccino I like to put them at a
plastic table with a lot of noise and
and Diet Coke so she met me at the
McDonald's and she was late and so when
she sat down I said tell me what you're
plan what you're doing and she started
describing this book you know and and it
sounded interesting like I was like this
sounds like a good project but I just
waited for my moment and then eventually
I said as I always say say to writers I
say so how much have you written and so
often almost always the answer is oh
well I haven't started writing anything
yet and I then I said to her I said well
you were 7 minutes late today and she
said I'm sorry you know she I'm so sorry
I'm like no no no my point was not that
you were 7 minutes late and I was upset
my point was I used the seven minutes
that you were late to write some
sentences you know I turned my computer
I said this is what I wrote in the seven
minutes that you were late right she was
a person who believed she could only
write in a two-hour block that her ideal
writing time was like 10 to 12 you know
that she needed to be in a certain place
in a certain mind frame which is so
often every creative person's belief
that they only work under certain
circumstances ideally so I reminded her
that during World War I there were men
in trenches wearing gas masks artillery
exploding over their heads and they were
scribbling in little books in journals
hoping that if they survive this battle
and the many battles that were to come
someday they might publish something so
thank goodness that the writers of the
1910s did not require Starbucks smooth
jazz and 2hour quiet blocks of time for
them to get their work done because
that's just not a reality especially if
you actually want to make a thing if you
want to do something like a vegetable
garden in your backyard or write a book
or create a YouTube channel if you
actually want to do it you should want
to be doing it whenever it's possible so
I I tell all of the creative people of
the world 10 minutes is precious to you
it doesn't mean in 10 minutes I can
write a chapter but you know in 10
minutes I can reread the last three
paragraphs I wrote earlier today and see
if they're okay and clean them up a
little bit or I can write five good new
sentences so it's just the idea that
people they just assume they need these
ideal situations in order to create
something lovely
you know whereas like van go was like
mentally unstable and unmedicated and
produce some of the greatest work in the
world you know but had he been living in
2022 people might have said well let's
get control of some of your mental
illness first let's experiment with some
medication before we get you painting
right like it's always this idea that
everything has to be right before we
launch and that's not true we should
just launch we launch now we're not the
Space Program we're not putting people
into orbit where we have to be careful
we just have to take steps forward and
um as is the case with most people she
really wasn't invested in writing she
was invested in the idea of having
written or in the idea that I can quit
my job and write from 10 to 12 every day
and then have lunch with my friends and
that is the writer's life which is as
you well know not the writer's
life nice um yeah I I think back to that
bit of your book whenever I feel like oh
you know I should I you know I should
probably do some book stuff right now
but I've I've only got 23 minutes until
you know until this thing that I have to
do and like oh you know I could go down
I could get a coffee get a biscuit just
like lounge around a bit I can't get
anything done in 23 minutes I need I
need hours and hours you know with my
with my flat whites in my hand like my
Lord of the Rings and my background
music to get into the Zone uh but I love
the way you put that of like in the
seven minutes I wrote some sentences and
I just thinking like if I I I I should
just have approach cuz like when I was
you know when I was when I was working
as a doctor um and trying to do the
YouTube thing on the side I would use
those 7 Minutes blocks of time here and
there to write stuff for videos like if
I'd be on the toilet instead of
scrolling Twitter on my phone I'd be on
notion typing out some stuff for a video
or if I'm waiting 8 minutes for a
patient's blood results to arrive and
there's no one else in the waiting room
and there's nothing for me to do it's
like great let's open up notion on the
Windows computers in front of me and
just like type out a few notes for a
video and so many people in my in my
Academy ask like oh but like I've got
I've got a job like how how do you do
YouTube alongside the job I'm always
like look man like there are very few
jobs where you don't have small small
amounts of time here and there where you
know which you normally waste scrolling
on your phone where if you wanted to and
if you really cared about this thing I'm
not saying you have to but if you did uh
you could potentially spend that time
opening up Apple notes and just drafting
a few bullet points for for your next
video and I think I've got that approach
to YouTube but I really don't have the
approach to the book because for the
book I've con I've talked myself into
believing the that like I need
to I need to have 4 hours and like the
appropriate coffee cup and all that crap
yeah well I wrote my fifth novel almost
all of it in faculty meetings while
teaching now admittedly it's a book of
lists it's a novel written by an
obsessive list maker so the book is told
or the story is told through list after
list after list after list but I wrote
almost all of those lists in those
moments of a faculty meeting when
something was being said that was
irrelevant to me which was an enormous
number number of minutes in those
faculty meetings or I always arrive 5
minutes early and I use those five
minutes and as things are wrapping up or
we have a raffle at the end of it
because that's going to make us happy
I'd just be writing lists and the beauty
of that was I didn't even need to write
on a computer I could have a Post-It
note that I'm writing a list on and that
can later be transferred into the
computer I wrote a whole book during
meetings and you know I always remind
people a book is probably about 5,000
sentences so like incrementalism right
pile up 5,000 sentences and you have a
book I can't guarantee that's it's going
to be a good book that depends on you
and your effort and skill and experience
but it's 5,000 sentences and if I write
seven sentences here I am a lot closer
to 5,000 than I was a minute ago I
really believe that that seven sentence
step forward is a significant one
especially because I know I'll do that
23 times today I'll take 23 moments in
my day to write somewhere between one
and 50 sentences and if I just keep
doing that you know that is why I have a
pile of books you know it's and you know
I'm a school teacher you know I am a
wedding DJ I have a Consulting business
I'm launching another business I do a
I'm a minister I officiate weddings I'm
a substitute minister at churches even
though I really don't have a lot of
faith in God I do all these things and
people the reason I wrote my book was
because people would ask me how do you
do all that you do and I would always
say well if you give me 12 hours I'll
sit down with you and I'll go through
your whole life and I'll help you you
out and no one wants to do that so the
book was the answer to that question um
but yeah same thing with writing is with
everything else people get very precious
over how a creative person works or how
creativity Works whether that creativity
is writing a book painting a painting or
figuring out how you going to you know
lay out your vegetable garden or my son
right he's a fish he's taking up fishing
this summer he loves it he's obsessed
with fishing and you know he had his
tackle box and he bought all this gear
and I said all right when you going to
set it up and he said right now and I
said well you got to go to bed in 10
minutes and he goes I can get some of it
done in 10 minutes Dad and I was like
damn he is right like I was going to
tell him don't start setting up your
tackle box now wait for the morning but
he was like no I'll get some of it done
I got 10 minutes before you're going to
make me brush my teeth that's exactly
the attitude you have to have I've been
obsessed with productivity for quite a
while um I found that when I was at when
I was at University going through
medical school and trying to build my
first business on the side
I realized that I had to find ways to
become more productive and ways to work
harder and work smarter and learn how to
study efficiently and stuff so that I
could have the time to do the things
that I wanted to do but then and so that
worked throughout University but then
when I started working full-time as a
doctor um that was like a step up in
terms of like oh you know I didn't think
I had free time at University now I
really don't have free time cuz like at
University even even in medical school
going into the hospital is kind of
optional you wake up in the morning and
you're like don't if I feel like going
in today um or yeah I'll go in for a few
hours I'll leave at lunchtime and then
do my own like self-study when you have
a job that you know that's just that's
unfeasible like you have to show up and
so all of a sudden like 10 to 12 hours
of every single day were just being
blocked up by work and I was trying to
grow the YouTube channel on the side and
I had a lots of periods of where I felt
pretty overwhelmed and pretty stressed
by the demands of work plus the demands
of the YouTube channel and so that was
when I was like okay I need to change my
approach to productivity as where this
idea of sort of feeling good like
positive emotions and stuff landed cuz I
didn't really want to be in a position
where every day felt like a grind cuz I
was in that mode for a while I was like
okay what if being productive and like
doing the things I wanted to do didn't
have to come at the expense of my like
physical and mental health what if I
actually could feel good while also
being productive and then I went on this
whole like research rabbit hole and
found that actually feeling good is one
of the keys to productivity and actually
the more positive emotion we feel in our
work the more productive we become but
also the more energy we have to give to
the other important things in other life
and so to me Feelgood productivity
became this sort of like holistic
philosophy that I you know I I I use
every day when like whenever I'm doing
something and it feels bad or I feel
blocked or I feel like kind of the the
negative emotions getting in the way I
remember I sort of remind myself that
okay no there are ways to make any
situation feel better and the way ways
to experience the positive emotion and
everything and it just means that I can
float through life FL through life I it
means I can go through life feeling
better about the work that I'm doing
while also being prettyy pretty
effective at the work and and and it's
interesting I guess because you have
both types of experience so you know
when you were working as a doctor in
hospital where when you're dealing with
people who are really unwell or really
highly stressful situations it must be
really hard to find the pleasure in that
kind of work in comparison to you know a
YouTube life and and where you can kind
of choose your hours a bit more or do
things that you're interested in so were
there quite different challenges yeah so
this is the thing so when I first
started started working I found it very
like stressful and sort of these high
high stress
situations and most of the doctors
around me also had that approach where
it was like there was this sense of like
uh kind of tension and stress in the air
but not everyone was like that and I had
a few seniors who I really looked up to
who were just like they were really good
doctors but they were they were also
happy they were like they had a smile on
their face they would crack jokes and it
kind of helped me realize that actually
there is another way
like approaching work as if it was it
was really stressful was actually a
choice that I was making and so I did
also make a concerted effort in my day
job to enjoy the day-to-day a little bit
more and kind of modeling the doctors
that I'd seen who would have Smiles on
their face and stuff
started it sounds weird but approaching
it with more lightness and ease almost
as if I was playing a game kind of um
and it's not playing a game in the sense
of you know people's lives are at stake
but there's a line from gry's Anatomy
that I I often thought about which is
when uh Derek Shepard the neurosurgeon
when he starts his operation he says he
puts a music on and he says to it and he
says to his team it's a beautiful day to
save lives let's have some fun and
obviously you know that's a fictional
fictional drama but there's something
about that that even when you're doing
neurosurgery even when it's just like
like life and death is in the balance it
can still be a beautiful day to save
lives you can still have fun along the
way and so much of that I found is a
choice that we make ourselves rather
than a rather than a thing that's foed
upon us by the environment yeah and I
guess with any job however difficult or
kind of emotionally taxing is there's
always something to be grateful for or
something to find in it that we feel
thankful for or find even the slightest
pleasure in I guess yeah I think I think
gratitude is a is a really major part of
this um the other one is you know this
is the first chapter of the book is the
idea of approach approaching work in the
spirit of play where yes even even when
the thing is really stressful you can
still choose to approach it in the
spirit of play
and you know there's so many stories of
Nobel Prize winners who found you know
the key to their productivity and the
key to their creativity was kind of
treating it with a little less
seriousness yeah and heaviness that we
tend to approach work with even when
it's heavy and serious like working in
medicine or being a therapist and things
just choosing to approach it with a
little bit more lightness and ease yeah
so I tried to kind of I I tried to do
that when I was in the day job and
especially now running this business and
having a team and stuff
again a lot of people I a lot of
business I knows a lot of business
owners I know are pretty stressed
because of the demands of running a
business and managing payroll and having
all these people dependent on you but at
the same time it's it's a bit of a game
approaching it in the spirit of play
yeah yeah that the the the idea that
that Joy is the most kind of important
factor when it comes to being
productive is
that at the core of this whole thing so
it's a sort of that's where you start
yeah sort of um so the the scientific
basis for this is a theory called the
broaden and build Theory um so there's
this researcher in the early 2000 called
Barbara fredericksen who kind of coined
this Theory to basically explain the
fact that when we experience positive
emotions it boosts our performance in
almost everything it boosts our
creativity and it lowers our stress and
you know her Theory very Loosely is like
if you imagine back in caveman days cuz
we're still operating with caveman
brains back in the caveman days
if if life is good if you're feeling
positive emotions it means that you're
not in danger of being eaten by a lion
the group is surviving life is good and
so you're more open to exploring and you
go out into your environment and you
forage the new stuff and you see you see
if you can make some new alliances
whereas when you experience negative
emotion like fear or stress or anxiety
it's like uhoh my life's in danger a
lion could be around the corner and you
your entire being contracts and you go
tunnel vision for survival and when
you're in that survival mode it's a very
high stress State because the body is
literally kind of trying to survive
whereas when you're in that kind of
broaden stage it's like broad it
broadens your repertoire of things that
you can do and it builds like resources
like alliances and like creativity and
things like that um and so that was like
a thing that I came across in my
research um where I felt that that was
really the key and so if we can
experience positive emotions joy in our
work it just has all of these benefits
it generates more energy for us and
often for a lot of us time isn't
necessarily the limiting factor energy
is the limiting factor but you know when
you when you experience joy and
positivity in your work you end up with
Boundless Energy and you as a side
effect you become more productive in
your work but then outside of work you
also have way more energy to give to the
other important things in your life yeah
and it's interesting because you there's
um uh sort of Lit Literature around that
idea but in young children so sort of
that you know if you have a a young
toddler for example and they they are in
a kind of threat mode and they'll feel
anxious and they'll go to their mother
to feel safe and then once they you know
they get that reassurance and they feel
safe or they receive a positive emotion
or experience a positive emotion from an
interaction with that mother they'll
then go out and take more risks and and
dive into whatever the situation is and
play with other children all they needed
was to feel safe and to have a sort of
positive emotion and then they're ready
to go out again and and experence so
does it sort of help with risk taking
and trying new things or creativity is
all kind of absolutely no I think that's
a great that's a great example with the
with the kids I wish I thought to put
that in the book cuz that's that's
absolutely
perfect we'll do some edit to the book
um no it's like yeah there's just so
much evidence so the there was a the
first study that really tested this I
think it was from from like the 1980s
there's this thing called uh I think
it's called the matchbox
puzzle what's to that effect where you
give you know they get people in a in a
lab and they give them like a matchbox
and a candle and like some like fun
thumb tacks those are things that you
yeah pins put stuff in the wall and you
know the challenge is find a way to get
the candle to light the candle but
without any any wax dripping onto the
floor or something to that effect and
this is like a classic test of
creativity because people who are more
creative in that moment will discover
the solution where people who are less
creative won't and they found that if
you prime people with positive emotions
like giving them a more teaser or
something just before they do the thing
they're like way more likely to solve
the puzzle through creativity amazing
and so was that study that was in I
think in the 1980s that sort of helped
spawn this wave of research into how
even for adults positive emotions do
make us more creative yeah and
increasingly in the world that we live
in where most people watching or
listening to this are probably knowledge
workers or students of some sort
productivity is actually more about
being creative and thinking broader than
it is about just like efficiently
cranking out more and more widgets so I
can eat chocolate all the way through
when writing absolutely yeah AB going to
help me with our creativity absolutely
yeah more the more we feel good the more
productive we are that's a great piece
of research so I hope this video has
given you a little bit of a different
perspective on productivity with all
this advice we do want to take it with a
little bit of a pinch of salt because no
one really knows what they're talking
about including me I've written a book
about productivity the way I think of it
is it is that it's all about
experimentation different things are
going to work for different people so if
you found an idea that has resonated
with you in this video or this episode
wherever you happen to be watching or
listening to this and I hope you'll
experiment with it you'll apply it to
your own life and you'll see if it works
for you if it does amazing and if not
then that's also okay it gives you an
interesting data point so thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you next
time bye-bye